my name is kaylee i have a youtube
channel called the dolls in the rain and
i restore american girl dolls i'm going
to walk you through how i restore a
1990s felicity american girl doll
felicity merriman is one of american
girls six original historical characters
originally this doll would have sold for
around a hundred dollars but in its
current state it is worth about 55
after i restore her she'll probably be
worth around 200
felicity's biggest problems are
definitely her missing arm she has nail
polish on all of her hands and feet her
hair is very messy and the face paint is
faded
[Music]
so the first thing i'm doing is taking
off felicity's head i'm doing this by
untying her next ring i'm using a sewing
pin to help get the knot undone
[Music]
then once it's untied i'm just pulling
off her head
[Music]
now that her head is de-attached i'm
removing all of her stuffing i'm just
pulling it out by hand and collecting it
in a pile so i can use it again later on
[Music]
now that felicity is unstuffed i'm going
to take off her limbs so i'm just
untying these and again i'm using a
sewing pin to help undo the knots
now i have felicity's limbs de-attached
and next i'll be removing the tension
cups from inside of her arms and legs to
do this i'm putting her limbs into a
ziploc bag and boiling water in a kettle
i want the water to be boiling hot so
the vinyl melts
once the water is boiled i'm putting the
ziploc bag into the water and leaving it
there for about a minute this is going
to heat up the limbs so i can remove the
tension cups without cracking the limbs
now that the limbs are heated up i'm
using a pair of needle nose pliers to
pull the tension cups out
next i'm going to be cleaning felicity
felicity has nail polish on her
fingernails and her toenails american
girl dolls should not have nail polish
so obviously her previous owner has
painted them
[Music]
to do this i'm using non-acetone nail
polish remover it's very important to
use non-acetone nail polish remover as
acetone can damage vinyl
all i'm doing is putting the nail polish
remover onto a cotton ball and rubbing
the nail polish off
once i have most of it off i'm using a
fine q-tip to get into the crevices of
the nails
[Music]
now that all of the nail polish is off
i'm using a magic eraser to clean the
rest of her skin
over time american girl dolls can get
very dirty you can see this when they
are shiny it's just a collection of
grease and sometimes the oil from your
hands
i'm also using a magic eraser on her
face but i'm being very careful not to
scrub too hard on her lips and eyebrows
because this can remove the paint
[Music]
now that felicity is clean i'm going to
restring her
[Music]
now that all of her limbs are attached
to her body i am re-stuffing felicity
[Music]
once i have all of the stuffing back in
i reattach felicity's head i just put it
back into the opening and tie the string
tight
[Music]
now i'm going to begin fixing felicity's
hair which is one of the hardest parts
of restoring an old doll her hair is
very frizzy and matted
i use a spray bottle and a wired hair
brush to help get all of the knots out
when i'm brushing doll hair i always
start from the bottom of the wig and
then work my way upwards so i'm not
dragging down the knots to the bottom of
the hair
next i'll be straightening felicity's
hair i'm doing this to remove the frizz
i'm making sure her hair is very wet as
using a straightener on dry american
girl doll hair can burn it
i finished straightening all of
felicity's hair and usually i would stop
there but felicity has pin curls at the
front of her head so i need to re-curl
those
i've straightened each of the three pin
curls and i'm going to be using a straw
and boiling water to get them back to
their original shape
i'm tying each little curl around a
plastic straw and securing it in place
with a bobby pin
[Music]
now i'm dipping the side of her head
into boiling water
i'm leaving it there for about 30
seconds
then i'm taking her head back out and
leaving her to dry
next i'm just removing the plastic
straws and her curls are back
[Music]
overall felicity's face paint has
definitely faded over time
her lips are faded her teeth are faded
her cheeks are faded and there is some
damage to her eyebrows
i'm using watercolors to paint
felicity's face i think it gives the
dolls a really natural look especially
with the older dolls that didn't have as
dramatic makeup as the newer dolls have
i'm using a very fine paint brush and
tracing over the lips that were already
there
i do this in one thin layer at a time
and then i blot it with a tissue
i'm happy with the shape of her lips i
can move on to the cheeks i'm using a
slightly bigger paintbrush here
i always leave it slightly lighter than
i would like because it dries dark
[Music]
i'm using some white acrylic craft paint
and very carefully filling in the teeth
[Music]
now that her teeth are done my last step
is to fill in her eyebrows
now that felicity is finished i've tied
her hair into her original hairstyle
with a little white ribbon in the back i
put her in this purple dress this is
from a newer edition of felicity now she
is ready to go on to her next owner and
be loved once again
[Music]